[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar xuv spectroscopy fundamentals
advantages and developments for probing
surface and interfacial charge carrier
dynamics
i am marie stone of labrutz and i'll be
your moderator
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by andor to learn more visit
andor.oxinst.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
emily herska
phd candidate at ohio state university
emily you may now begin your
presentation
hi everyone my name is emily hiroska i'm
a student in dr robert baker's group at
ohio state university i'm really excited
to introduce everybody at andor today to
some more background of xv spectroscopy
fundamentals specifically i'll highlight
the advantages and developments of the
method that have been critical for my
graduate research and in general for
better probing surface and interfacial
dynamics that's so critical for
chemistry today
so a little bit about my group i'm
actually a fourth year phd student not a
faculty member so hopefully my
understanding is enough to
kind of wet your palette about xp
spectroscopy but i am a graduate student
at ohio state university which if you're
unfamiliar is in columbus ohio we are
happy to host visitors
from a lot of the vendors we work with
so if you're ever in the columbus area
and you want to see our
super cool basement laser lab
feel free to reach out to me
and
uh you might also find yourself at our
pretty famous football stadium which is
shaped like a horseshoe for
reasons i do not understand
and
more importantly we have the best damn
band in the land and here is a photo of
our marching band
spelling out the script ohio which they
do
multiple times at every football game if
you ever want to see that happen as well
but scoping out to the greater osu
campus
here you can also see our
pretty
picturesque oval
the chemistry department is somewhere in
the middle far away from all of these
beautiful things and that is where
we spend most of our time in the
basement in the dark in the cold doing
some xuv spectroscopy experiments
and
just to give a little bit more
background about my group dr robert
baker is the pi of the group our website
is listed here as well as his email
which i'll show again later
he is happy to
answer questions or talk about any of
any of the applications that you might
see that maybe i can't answer questions
about
and then also a few pictures of my group
i realize now that i'm not on video but
i'm kind of in the center of this
picture so that's
easy to find um and these are people
that have worked on some of the
applications i'll show later so i wanted
to make sure that they're highlighted at
the beginning of the talk as well
just to give some
due credit for a lot of the hard work
that goes on in our lab
so i also wanted to mention that there's
been a recent paper that goes into much
more detail on the work i'll describe
today published by my pi and a former
grad student who's now a postdoc at
princeton i'll reference it throughout
here because many great examples and
some of the more detailed mathematical
descriptions of xcv science can be found
there
but in general the message today is to
understand how extreme ultraviolet pump
probe spectroscopy can provide element
oxidation state surface and spin state
specific charge carrier dynamics with a
femtosecond ultra fast time resolution
the learning objectives that i shared
before the webinar are also
going to kind of outline the talk today
so i
i want to first focus on identifying
advantages and challenges of the theory
behind xv spectroscopy and why it's
taken so long to develop
second i would like to really focus on
some of the novel physical capabilities
of tabletop lab xuv instrumentation so
as opposed to things that synchrotrons
are x-ray free electron lasers what
really happens in a lab-based xuv
spectrometer
and lastly i'll highlight some early
examples of successful studies that have
been completed in the xuv field these
are going to directly correlate with
some of the
physical attributes of the method
and i'll just use those to kind of back
up my justification of
you know what is element specificity
what is spin state specificity those
kinds of things and how these attributes
are really helpful for
interfacial studies
and then lastly i would like to talk
about sort of the future direction of
the field that's happening both in the
baker group but outside of our group as
well
so first i would just like to make sure
we're all in the same understanding
about what is xuv before i joined my
research group at ohio state i had no i
never heard of this term before so xuv
or euv
is extreme ultraviolet so in the grand
scheme of the electromagnetic spectrum
this is somewhere between uv and x-rays
so that kind of helps the name make a
little bit more sense but specifically
we primarily are talking about
approximately 10 to 124 ev or if you
think in nanometers 124 to 10 nanometers
which is a
right in the window of easy conversion
but this is um
this is sort of our window of
experimentation that i will highlight
what do these transitions mean but also
what does this specific
energy region provide us with in terms
of experimentation
so
this xuv level uh excitation energy
between 10 to 124 ev this is quite
different from what most
spectroscopic methods have used for a
long time now so uv visible near ir
these all have much lower energy
excitation energies and that means that
their
their window to probe is limited to sort
of the most valence density of states
and when you're probing this valence to
conduction band type of region you're
really probing a
an average of
sort of a distribution of states so we
think of in solids materials the valence
states are kind of a band of states
rather than discrete orbitals at this
point and so when you probe an
excitation between these states you get
many overlapping features you get
features that are broadened or shifted
because of bonding at specific atoms and
this causes a lot of
just
unclear assignments of peaks and spectra
that have sort of indiscriminate
fittings to them oftentimes we see you
know one really large peak with several
gaussians and you have to try to discern
which excitation you're looking at
in each
of the minor gaussians and this can be
pretty complicated although it's been
around for a while so many groups are
finding ways to get around this
complicated assignment and still doing
really interesting and
expertise uh
projects and research with this type of
method but the good thing about xv
spectroscopy is we're actually probing a
core state into our valence states so
our excitation can
can utilize this much higher energy
and
promote an electron from this core to
valence state
so because these core levels don't
participate in bonding they're not going
to be broadened and shifted when we look
at the the end game spectrum so this
core whole energy can actually act as an
element specific tag we'll look at
something like a metal m edge or an
oxygen l edge which
would be like our three p or our
uh our two s states
in these specific cases and will excite
into our most valence state so maybe a
metal 3d state or an oxygen 2p state
so these
these energies again will be essentially
an element specific tag and when we look
at the
specific excitation energy for this xv
window we actually have many
orbital edges that we can probe across
the periodic table so here i'm
highlighting
the first 22 and we can basically see
that within this window we have many
many
bands that we might be able to probe so
these low
uh low atomic number elements you know
these are a little bit more challenging
because we don't have many solid state
samples which i'll discuss later why
solid state is so easy and gas phase or
liquid phase might be harder but
um you know we
in the baker group mainly look at things
like transition metal oxides so if i
just scan over to the next slide here
you can see that a lot of the
interesting metals that are at the
forefront of materials signs today
have several
several transitions that are within this
probe window so we see that nickel has
some m
edge character which is our 3p shell
right sort of smack in the middle of our
window manganese iron cobalt copper
these are all samples that have been
studied
in our group as well as many of the
sort of you know forefront of xuv
spectroscopists today who are still
developing this type of
method but these are sort of the
the model systems that we look at and we
can examine you know much higher atomic
order metallic systems as well
but in general you know xuv people think
oh this kind of limits you because the
excitation energy is so small you
probably are limited to what you can
study but in actuality
every
um every element that's sort of
interesting in chemistry today
has some orbital that lies within this
energy and we can probe these
transitions and this just will allow us
to understand what's happening at the
valence shell so we're still going to be
analyzing electron and whole motion
throughout the valence and conduction
bands but we'll just be probing that
with an element specific tag that's due
to that core level excitation
so taking a step back so that's you know
sort of what is xtv but we want to also
understand where is fcp science at today
and so i've just put together this rough
timeline of sort of the history of xcv
science to get a better grasp on why the
developments are where they are today
so xuv really is tied to the development
of x-ray science which is you know
nominally very closely tied together
because the energy windows are so close
in this super high energy but sort of
invisible light is
you know much more challenging to
understand than something like visible
light or uv light where you can kind of
um you know understand certain
properties just with the naked eye and
this led to a much earlier investigation
whereas x-ray and xuv science is just in
development um still in you know still
in today
but in the late 1800s we have the
discovery of x-rays which led to the use
of x-rays for science and chemistry in
the early 1900s where we started to
understand crystal diffraction patterns
and we started to really understand what
xvp spectra or sorry x-ray spectroscopy
could be so we can understand elemental
shifts we can understand chemical shifts
and this all started in the early
development in the in the early to mid
1900s
in 1930 lawrence and livingston built
the first cyclotron at berkeley
and this is uh you know directly tied to
the
lab that's still there today but
cyclotrons had a slightly different
setup than synchrotrons where cyclotrons
had these fixed magnetic fields
and the bending of these charged
particles was essentially proportional
to the momentum so the cyclotrons were
limited to
fairly low energies and after that the
expansion of these facilities became
unaffordably large
so in 1947 ge sponsored the building and
the investigation of the the first
artificial synchrotron light which was
still using visible light but this was
um really
been a key development in in the concept
of accelerating particles with higher
energies
and this is this is basically the the
first synchrotron as we know it today
in 1956 we had the first x-ray
synchrotron study which happened at
cornell
and this again was really critical to
the development of x-rays as we started
to have these large-scale facilities
where users could come and uh perform
x-ray studies that couldn't be done in
their lab so it was really essential to
have facilities across the nation and
really in other countries across the
world as well so that experimenters
could start to figure out what x-ray
spectroscopy could do for them
in the 70s we had the first 4th gen
light source which was a free electron
laser that was built at stanford so this
opened the window to coherent light
sources and this is also critical for
many xuv experiments we need coherent
light sources which is why x-ray free
electron lasers are so
so important but then we found in the
late 80s and then
through the 90s the development of
high harmonic generation and gases so
this is a process i'll describe in a
little bit but this is how we can
produce soft x-rays in the low hundreds
of evs to even less than 100 ev
and this is how um
uh the development from mcpherson and
then corkman shaffer later in the xuv
window of high harmonic generation
really enables what my group does today
in our laser lab
and then from the 90s through today
we're still developing lab-based and
facility-based xuv techniques and
practices
there are still many directions that the
field can go that we haven't quite
figured out yet so the development is
going to be
really something that happens throughout
our lifetimes and it's quite exciting to
see how how this path
comes about
so the benefits of xuv spectroscopy i'll
get into a little bit many of these
relate to x-ray spectroscopy in general
not just extreme ultraviolet but x-ray
as well and i'll highlight the xuv
specific ones in a little bit the first
that i'll talk about is element
specificity so
here i'm showing um from my own group's
research spectrum where we can see the
energy windows from 35 to 80 ev so this
is xuv but the same principle applies to
x-ray spectroscopy in general we're
looking at the m23 edge absorption so
this is 3p to 3d transitions
and what we can see here is that the
image transition energy is increasing as
the atomic number of the metal increases
so we're going from titanium to copper
here and we can see that the the peaks
are shifting to a much higher energy as
we go so the effective nuclear charge is
increasing from left to right on the
periodic table and this directly
causes this shift of excitation energy
so what we're saying is that we're
actually retaining the element-specific
signature of x-ray spectroscopy and this
is essentially due to the core to
valence uh principle of how x-ray and
xuv spectroscopy work but in practice
this is quite useful because in these
cases we have all single metal
uh oxide structures so titanium dioxide
or
hematite which is just iron and oxygen
but in principle and in practice
actually right now we can construct
samples that are maybe more interesting
that have multiple metal centers in one
sample and for instance if we have
something that involves titanium and
copper
the signatures for these metal centers
are quite separable so we can directly
probe one sample and understand
what's happening at the titanium sites
versus what's happening at the copper
sites
this has been done
in our group as well as in others we've
studied heterostructures that involve
nickel oxide hematite titanium dioxide
silicon there's many structures that are
possible that we can sort of build that
maybe have better applications for
photocatalytic practices but this is the
first benefit that we see for activity
spectroscopy
the second benefit that that we'll see
is spin state sensitivity so here is a
figure from a paper by the chain group
and we see that the
again m23 edge absorption these are both
iron complexes but one has um
has a spin a quintet spin and the other
has a singlet and what we can see is
that in this case where they measure the
bulk uh
thin films of molecular complexes they
they can display that the shape and
position are both sensitive to the iron
spin state
so the
um the ligand field is the same and the
oxidation state is the same for the
metals but the
spin state is actually directly shifting
this primary peak
by a couple of ev and the shape is
dramatically changed as you can see
visibly so spin state sensitivity is
going to be critical for
understanding how
electron spin is affecting something
like magnetic properties or even
catalytic processes can involve a spin
crossover or spin flip so
again this is
a an xcv specific
benefit that is not well seen in uv viz
spectroscopy for example where the spin
state is sort of buried within
much more information that you can
extract from the valence states
themselves
so maybe i kind of gave this away in the
last slide but
here we also see that the oxidation
state can affect our signal so in this
case we have um again from the same
paper where they're highlighting xuv
spectroscopy we see that the cobalt spin
oxidation state is changing from uh plus
two to plus three between these samples
now the spin state is also changing here
so it's a little bit complicated the
paper has a much more uh
grand figure where they kind of extract
how all of these are related but you'll
just have to trust me when i say that
the reduction of the
cobalt metal from a plus three to a plus
two state is causing this redshift of
the the cobalt main peak from about 64
ev to about 61ev
so we see this many times in excited
states where a reduction or an oxidation
of a metal center
will actually cause a red shift or a
blue shift of your main feature and
this has helped with many assignments in
my group this is sort of like our very
first
um
question when we're doing an experiment
is if you cite an electron into a metal
center now you've reduced that do we see
a redshift as we expect and this is sort
of the basics of assigning x-ray excited
state dynamics
okay and then the fourth uh benefit that
i'll highlight here for fcv spectroscopy
is you can also extract um information
about the coordination geometry of your
metal center so here's the same um
so here's the same um
uh structures with the cobalt the cobalt
metal centers where we have the
two plus oxidation state different spin
states but we also have different
coordinations around the metal centers
and what we find is that the the shape
again is being
adjusted based on the coordination so
you might have more or less intensity at
a certain feature or entirely new peaks
and this is all due to the bonding
structure of your valence your valence
shell so
as i mentioned before
the core levels aren't participating in
bonding so they won't be shifted however
if we compare
two different
uh states of the similar sample that
have different valence bonding what we
would find is that the excitation from a
core level into that valence state will
be adjusted based on how the
how the external orbitals are
participating in bonding how they might
be hybridized how they might be
you know sort of minimized in energy in
terms of stabilization or
destabilization because of the external
ligand field so this is all extracted
with xuv spectroscopy as well
and as i mentioned before these four
qualities are all
general phenomena that are true for core
level spectroscopy in general so this
ranges from xuv to soft and hard x-ray
regimes as well
however the ability to measure core hole
spectra using a tabletop instrument
with ultra fast time resolution
is
what's going to make xuv spectroscopy
suitable for studying surfaces in a lab
rather than a facility
so here is just a highlight of some of
the facility options that are available
and i'll just briefly describe because
probably many people at andor are
already familiar with synchrotrons and
x-ray for your electron lasers but these
large-scale facilities which were
developed again in the mid to late 1900s
are really great workhorses for the
field of xuv and x-ray science they can
you know really enable many people to
travel and perform experiments at these
large-scale facilities and because of
funding and just general accessibility
in in terms of you know experimentation
on site they really enable a range of of
different research
ideas that are
great and very beneficial for the field
with that being said
traveling to a synchrotron writing a
proposal
getting the time the beam time that you
need can be quite expensive both in cost
and in time and
um you know there aren't very many of
these light sources uh you know
in the grand scheme of things across the
us or the world even
and the ones that are available
sometimes you can't do the ideal
experiment they have lower time
resolution so at synchrotrons we can
either do picosecond time resolution or
we can start to stretch into the
femtosecond regime but we have to
take a hit on the the flux that we get
so you know it's kind of a trade-off
experimentally
with x-ray free electron lasers we
started to get into femtosecond pulses
with coherent x-ray light so this is
great but again you're gonna have to
travel get the beam time
you know you have a week to do your
experiments and if they don't work you
have to come back in six months so
the benefit of having a lab option is
you know i can just go to the basement
and you know walk down the hall and do
my experiments all night if i want to
and you know probably i don't want to
but i do it anyway because i can get the
data that i need right there at my
leisure so
while these large scale facilities are
the workhorse for x-ray and xuv science
these experimental limitations and the
accessibility constraints have led to
this push for
the development of tabletop instruments
that we can we can all start to develop
in our own labs
so this is um sort of the grand scheme
of our
our instrumentation which doesn't
actually look that complicated when you
look at it in the scheme we do have
some you know
some boxes on the side which are
generating our our fundamental beam so
we have a titanium sapphire regen
regenerative amplifier system this is
going to generate an 800 nanometer
uh wavelength beam with 35 femtosecond
pulse duration at a kilohertz repetition
rate
we have a total output of about 6
millijoules uh pulse energy so this is
all going to happen kind of off the
screen here i didn't include because
everything on the screen here is
actually home built and a little bit
more interesting and actually what's the
requirement for xuv spectroscopy
so we separate our fundamental beam into
two path lengths first i'll highlight
the pump path length because that's uh a
little bit more probably familiar so we
take our 800 nanometer beam
using a bbo crystal we can convert this
to 400 nanometer or 267 nanometer we
also have an opa but we generally just
use 400 or 267
wavelength light this uh this pump beam
goes through this retro reflector mirror
which generates our time delay when we
want to control
um transient spectrum
uh with this pump probe method so we'll
separate move this this mirror on a
stage in order to
to set you know increase or decrease the
pass length to
to create the time delay and then this
pump theme basically just enters the
chamber and interacts with the sample
so more interesting is the xcv path
which is
um
the purpose of the webinar so
the xcv beam
has very high attenuation in air or
really in any most materials so we do
all of this under vacuum
so the
the 800 nanometer beam enters the vacuum
chamber here the first chamber which is
our fcv generation chamber so this is
where a higher harmonic generation takes
place i'll talk about that in a moment
once we get through this
chamber which has a gas cell um we're
going to actually filter out the 800
nanometer beam so through this tube is
just the xuv beam propagating
the xuv beam reflects off of a toroidal
mirror which is at a grazing angle to
minimize the loss of xuv
absorption in the in the gold-coated
mirror
and then from there
we just again go through some filters
and then interact with the sample
so in our case
you'll notice that the sample is kind of
in the plane of the xcd propagation so
we are actually reflecting
off of the sample and then onto grading
and finally collecting on the ccd
but there's also options for
transmission through a sample
um or absorption i guess you could call
it i'll talk about these in a little bit
this is a pretty critical choice for
what happens with your xuv
uh
spectrum at the end of the day but um
yeah this is this is a critical choice
but first i'll highlight what higher
hormone generation is taking place so
this is a highly non-linear strong field
process that operates in the
non-perturbative
regime so it's a it's a pretty physical
process that's studied by many people um
in physics mostly so in chemistry we
utilize it gladly but we don't study it
in depth but i'll just give a an overall
uh description of how this enables the
production of xuv and soft x-ray pulses
with femtosecond to autosecond pulse
durations so
essentially we have the 800 nanometer
beam and we also have a 400 nanometer
beam that focused at the end of this gas
cell they overlap in time and in space
and here is where the
xcv production will occur so in step one
here we have the tunnel ionization of an
electron from its gas uh gas parent atom
potential
into the continuum so this happens due
to the distortion
of the atomic binding potential in this
high intensity electric field so at the
minimum we would distort it one way and
that electron in the gas gas atom can
tunnel ionize out of its potential
then as the laser field flips
um we're going to actually accelerate
this ejected electron back towards this
parent ion
when as the electric field kind of
reverses sine so we distort it the
opposite way and now that electron is
going to actually be accelerated back
and in step three activity beam is
created as the electron recombines with
with its parent ion it's going to
re
sorry it's going to release this uh this
photon which is going to be an xcv
window depending on
the um
depending on the energy of every process
that's happening here so
the maximum xcv photon
is going to have energy proportional to
the electron ponderomotive energy gained
in the strong laser field plus the
ionization potential of the specific
generation medium or the gas that you
use
um and so there's a lot of math and
physics that go into this energy but
basically with 800 nanometer light at
pulse intensities around 10 to the 15
watt watts per centimeter squared we can
produce xtv photon energies you know
between like 30 and 80 ev
uh and this is basically the focus of em
edge in transition metals so this is
pretty typical for a titanium sapphire
chirp pulse amplifier output
and we
we uh have kind of developed
the
the general setup that we use for this
is starting to be mocked up in a lot of
other labs as well so
the baker group was at the forefront of
developing this and dr baker in his
postdoc just uh i don't know like six or
seven years ago um worked on this
initial setup and now so we have it in
our lab as well
but this is this is an ideal case for
studying things like transition metal
oxides or
um sort of dimetallic or
you know multi-metallic complexes that
that have
something within the 30 to 80 or 90 ev
window
okay
um
[Music]
so i also mentioned that the choice
between reflection or transmission or
absorption sample models will be
critical so
at the beginning of development
transmission model setups were
were the go-to many
spectroscopic methods perform in this
setup
and so it's you know pretty common to
design
excuse me to design
an experiment that's based on this model
so basically you have your xcv light
that goes through the sample and then
you know maybe interacts with the
grating and then the detector
the limitation of transmission in xcv
experiments is that as i mentioned
before the xuv is highly attenuated in
air and most materials so
your
um your probe depth is going to be
proportional to the attenuation
coefficient which is alpha
but your sample has to be
extremely thin for this to work for you
to get essentially any xuv flux out of
your sample you also have to have a
highly homogenous structure because if
you start to probe through the bulk and
things are changing as you go
um you know your signal is going to have
just
magnifications of noise and you'll be
you'll have a challenge to discern what
your data actually means
in addition to to these problems
many theoretical studies have predicted
that the equilibrium structure and and
the non-equilibrium dynamics actually of
charge carriers are different at the
surface of your material versus the bulk
of the material
and this can be due to
interfacial bonding
um
the surface atoms could be could have
hosts different coordination
than the than the bulk atoms
um and you also often times see
see the segregation of structural
defects so defects oftentimes migrate to
the surface of your sample
where there may be more stable
so
so
all of these things have sort of uh
motivated dr baker to develop this
reflection absorption mode so this is
actually
xuvra spectroscopy which is um what's
kind of coined in all of the baker group
paper so far
but we basically take our xcv light and
reflect it off of the surface of the
sample at a grazing angle so we use
eight degrees um
but here you can see the math behind
what that does to the probe depth your
your probe depth is
altered by as a function of the sine of
your incidence angle
and so here for example with a with the
theta being 8 degrees the probe depth is
reduced by a factor of about
seven point two or seven point three so
what we see is that
we probe a much smaller region of the
the surface of our material
um the line shapes of transmission
versus reflection spectroscopy will turn
out different in your final spectrum
that you collect but
uh conveniently this is relatively
trivial to
to um
sort of compromise because there are
these developed mathematical
relationships the cramer's chronic
equations which allow you to basically
extract the same resonance information
from either setup
slides
okay
so now i'll just highlight one of our
last benefits which is specific to xuv
ra spectroscopy so i mentioned before
but the surface sensitivity is
going to
to allow us to really focus on the first
few nanometers or atomic layers of the
samples which oftentimes is what we're
most interested in so catalysis would
happen at the surface a lot of magnetic
properties sort of migrate to the
surface and so
setting the surface or being able to
study the interface between two
different materials
in xcv ra methods
is really another great benefit for us
so here we look at the xcdra intensity
versus the x-ray photoemission spectrum
quantification on this tio2 silicon
sample
and what they what we proposed in this
paper was that the xcv
edge intensity should saturate as a
function of thickness as you get to the
probe depth so once you reach the the
full probe depth you shouldn't be able
to get any more signal so if you're
increasing the thickness of your sample
you wouldn't see the thickness going up
once you get to the
you know few nanometers that you are
fully probing
and so
this
intensity saturation at higher film
thicknesses correlates to fitting this
xps signal to an exponential and so from
quantifying this we are able to
determine that the probe depth in this
specific case was about three nanometers
however this is
highly material dependent um so as i
mentioned before different materials can
attenuate the xuv beam
in different ways so the attenuation
coefficient allows us to quantify this
probe depth directly but you'll see that
for most material most transition metal
oxides that we've studied this is on the
scale of a few nanometers so really just
probing the top couple of atomic top
atomic layers
and then finally i'll just highlight uh
again i mentioned before femtosecond and
autosecond time resolution so in the
baker group specifically
we can map our instrument response
function as a convolution of two
gaussians we fit this from the
uh bleach kinetics
at the iron edge in hematite and this
can be some you know anywhere from like
40 to 90 femtoseconds depending on the
fit and the material that we're using
but this retains the time resolution
that's on par with these x-ray free
electron facilities
but again we're doing this in our own
lab so this is really benefiting us
because we can monitor those ultra-fast
processes
with coherent light in the xcv window
you know just down the hallway
so again to highlight our specific
instrumentation we have this higher
harmonic generation taking place in the
gas cell we have our sample in
reflection mode and both beams are
interacting with that sample
in
in
following that is our grading and our
ccd which we can collect really nice
harmonics and translate that to
really beautiful transient spectra
so
lastly i'd like to just highlight a few
examples of
some recent developments that that sort
of directly correlate with these
benefits i've described for axive
techniques so the first is being able to
understand surface versus bulk dynamics
in hematite so hematite which is this
iron oxide complex this is a highly
earth abundant photocatalyst it's
oftentimes used for model systems our
group has studied it a lot and many
people have followed that up with
with more experiments because this is a
really promising photo catalyst but it
suffers from poor carrier mobility so
these excited charge carriers could
perform photo catalytically but instead
they oftentimes self-trap which leads to
recombination and a quenching of any
photocatalytic activity
and this happens on this time scale of a
few hundred femtoseconds so being able
to probe where these electron and holes
are moving within your system is really
critical for understanding this process
better
um and what we find in our study was
that
there were predictions that indicated
that the kinetics of polaron formation
and hopping are unique to the surface
versus the bulk and they converge to
bulk behavior within a few atomic layers
so here's a contour plot of um the
excited hematite state excited with 400
nanometer light
and we see that um you know before time
zero there's no signal and then as you
excite your sample you have this
negative feature which
is there very early and shifts to
blue shifts to a higher energy and then
we have this positive feature which
grows in as well
so the model that was developed
is that in the excited state so we
excite with our optical light we have
this initial charge transfer state
um
the excited electrons can couple to
optical phonon modes in the hematite
sample and this results in an ultra fast
lattice distortion
and this is followed by polaron
formation
within several hundred femtoseconds
but if we take a look at the time scales
so
specifically the polaron state we can
notice that in the bulk
which is the black line this happens on
a time scale of 90 femtoseconds but at
the surface with xcdra which we which we
can probe we see that this is um
quite slower about three times slower at
250 femtoseconds
so the next example that i wanted to
highlight is the resolution between
electron and holes in metal oxide which
i have described just briefly before but
in the molecular image of looking at a
metal oxide structure we notice that
with a pump excitation from a valence to
conduction band we'll have a hole in our
oxygen valence band and a new electron
in our metallic conduction band what
this means is that a metallic emits
transition now we've lost some
some absorption potential because we
filled an empty state here whereas in
the oxygen l edge we've now gained
some xv intensity because we have a new
excitation pathway where our hole is so
by
understanding this molecular picture we
can actually
start to realize what the and predict
what the xv spectrum might look like we
would have positive intensity where we
have new absorption pathways and a
negative intensity where an electron is
now blocking
an absorption pathway
so this translates to
our spectra here on the right where we
have different metal edges nickel oxide
cobalt oxide and iron oxide again all of
these will appear at different energies
because of that element specific core
structure but in each case we have
positive and negative features where we
have new or removed absorption pathways
and in these three examples we also see
our oxygen l edge we have a positive
intensity here because we have that new
hole in our oxygen
ledge transition now in the 2p state the
only time we don't see our oxygen led is
in this iron disulfide where of course
we have no oxygen but what we do see is
that the iron positive and negative
features line up perfectly with the iron
oxide positive and negative features
because that iron center is not changing
the oxygen l edge you'll notice is
shifting a little bit this is
a direct relation to how those oxygen 2p
bonding states are covalently
interacting with a metal
metal center and this can be shifted
because of the covalency of that metal
and then at the bottom of this we have
this search paper
which is uh
going to directly show us a very similar
trend where we have um xcv
differentiating character carriers even
in single element semiconductors so this
case is for germanium where we have this
band diagram which shows what we're
exciting
basically a visible or near ir pump will
excite electrons into the conduction
band and leave behind a hole in the
valence band and the xuv beam can probe
both that hole and that electron by
showing us an increased intensity at the
hole and a decreased intensity
absorption where the electron is now
occupying that state so we have at the
whole an increased intensity and at the
electron we have a negative intensity
here
so these karyodynamics and
nanocrystalline
germanium or
other metallic systems can reveal
separate
dynamics that that importantly decay
together as those charges recombine so
that's really essential to assigning
those carriers
okay and then the final example that i
want to highlight
is
dynamics of spin states resolved by xuv
spectroscopy so here we studied some um
kind of complicated cobalt iron oxide so
we have two different metal centers
and this cobalt ferrite is a fairy
magnetic inverse spinel ferrite so the
iron three plus centers occupy all of
the tetrahedral and half of the
octahedral sites and then cobalt two
plus occupies half of the octahedral
sites
so here we found that with um
with xuv ra spectroscopy we were
actually able to
model and simulate the high spin versus
the low spin excited states
and for the sake of time i won't get
into a lot of the details of that
fitting but
basically we found that with this system
we could model that we have a high spin
initial state where the cobalt is in the
high spin and then we have a low spin
final state
which grows in as a function of time so
we're actually inducing a spin flip or a
spin crossover event on the time scale
of about 400 femtoseconds so this is
very similar to previous reports in
prussian blue analog systems
but we're able to resolve this uh ground
state excitation into a high spin state
and then decay into a low spin excited
state and this is really important
because we're understanding charge
carrier dynamics with spin sensitivity
which means we can
model
um
and sort of optimize materials that need
this sort of spin control
okay so some future directions for the
field that i'll highlight briefly
first there's a lot of work happening
right now to extend the capabilities of
hhg produced xuv light into the water
window which is between 280 to about 535
ev this will allow us to access carbon
nitrogen and oxygen k edges which are
really critical for most systems we find
a lot of carbon nitrogen and oxygen
present in
interesting metallic catalytic etc
systems
and we would also be able to study this
in liquid environments which is
something we're limited to in the baker
group we only can probe
solid solid systems and we could do
gases right now although solids are
usually more interesting so here's
just a spectrum where you can see that
the photon energy produced is greatly
expanded
um the second
future direction i'll highlight is xuv
magnetic circular dichroism where we
have the generation of circularly
polarized coherent xuv light um so we
produce circularly polarized rather than
linearly polarized xv light and then we
can use this light at the sample which
is in some magnetic field
to understand spin events at interfaces
and at surfaces so this is a figure from
a different reference which i'm
highlighting here they have a a
different set up so the setups are not
very uniform right now but basically
we're starting to look at xmcd signal
rather than x right mcd or um you know
just traditional magnetic circular
dichroism we can extend this into the
xev window and we're currently actively
working on this very diligently so
hopefully we'll have some papers to show
um you know in the short term and then
the final
application or future direction that um
i'll highlight is liquid sheet studies
so rather than liquid jet studies which
have been around for some time now um in
in the cylindrical jet options we have a
strong absorption at the the liquid
edges of the jet we have photon
scattering happen and refraction due to
that boundary between the liquid and the
vacuum and we also have a mismatch
between the jet diameter and the focus
size of the xev beam so
liquid jets have not really been
a promising
option for xuv studies but
by flattening those jets into these
liquid sheets which look something like
this
we can actually have tunable very thin
sheets that are able to
sort of propagate enough xv light that
we can study liquid samples or we can
study um sort of a solute in or sorry
it's a
solute inside of some kind of liquid
okay and then the last thing that i'll
highlight is just that there are some
ongoing technological advances also
underway to increase the brightness of
some tabletop light sources so the
national extreme ultra fast science
facility or nexus is one effort
so nexus is an nsf
sponsored uh mid-scale user facilities
so something between like a synchrotron
and a lab-based instrument this will be
open access to users
but it is being hosted at ohio state and
the director is dr baker mypi so at the
heart of this facility is a kilowatt
class ultra fast laser which provides
two orders of magnitude increase in the
xcv pulse repetition rate compared to
traditional hhg sources like in my lab
um
and so we have uh these specs for our
our laser that's coming in and we can
drive out of second and femtosecond xuv
and soft x-ray generation with this
laser
this xuv light will
will provide um
light for the these experimental end
stations so we have x-ray absorption or
x-ray reflection spectroscopy which is
what i've highlighted today
but we'll also have xcv light for angle
resolved photoelectron spectroscopy or
rpes
element specific scanning tunneling
microscopy or stm and out of second
science with uh laser induced electron
diffraction or lied
so
this isn't the only facility there's
also one in europe which is uh the
extreme light infrastructure auto second
light pulse source or eli alps and
facilities like these are really opening
the door to a variety of non-linear xv
measurements as well as ultra fast
in-situ measurements
that are currently limited by just a
lack of sufficient xv photon flux at at
larger scale facilities
so again just to highlight what nexus
specifically will do i won't get into
details here but
just a few examples of the different end
stations as well as the time resolutions
we expect here so going down to the auto
second resolution
the xuv specs on target are
um you know can be quite small and can
can have quite a broad uh
energy excitation energy window so 10 to
70 v is traditionally what we do that's
what will be provided for our pez but
for the xas and xrs at nexus we'll have
an expanded window from 15 up to 300 ev
so just to summarize with the nexus
facility why are we focused on these
higher repetition rates what's this
general benefit going to provide to us
well we're actually enabling a quantum
leap and sample throughput so in our
current state of the art high harmonic
generation and a tie staff laser system
which we have in our lab with a one
kilohertz repetition rate you know dr
baker writes okay the required sample
averaging is greater than 10 hours per
sample in reality we usually average on
a sample for a transient experiment up
to a few weeks of of experimentation but
at the nexus facility where we have 100
kilohertz now suddenly this is going to
take us a 10 hour sample would take us
less than 10 minutes so this is going to
really affect how much xuv science can
be done by
researchers across the country and
really across the globe in general at
this mid-scale facility you know it's
not going to be as big as the
synchrotron or an x-ray free electron
laser but we're really going to enable a
high throughput of different science and
different different projects that can
come through so lastly i'll just put put
out our little advertisement that we
have a user workshop coming up on july
25th and 26th
and because andor is really critical to
our development we're using an andor
camera for
the xas edge station um i'm not sure
about i work with xas so i'm not sure
about the other end stations but i'm
sure andor
would be well represented at this user
workshop and you can hear about a lot
more exciting and
you know upcoming potential experiments
that could happen at nexus as its
development comes to an end in the next
year or two
so with that i would like to
wrap up my talk and open the door to any
questions that you may have here i'm
listing my contact information as well
as dr baker's if you have questions and
here is again the citation for
the
the recent publication that i have
sort of modeled much of this information
on that goes into more detail there
and thank you for your time and i'm
happy to
thank you emily for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
so let's get started our first question
is
what kind of ionization medium is used
for the high harmonic generation process
okay this is a great question and we
actually had another question that came
in on a similar topic so
in the baker group we typically stick
with something like helium gas
or argon gas
um these provide us with pretty high
flux in the region that we're interested
in which again is about 30 to 70 ev but
really any um noble gas that has an
ionization potential within the xv
window
could be usable and depending on the gas
you choose you can tune a little bit
much energy
region you
get the most xcv flux within
um and just to address the second half
of the other question that came in about
the spot size so with our setup um and
our focal length from our toroidal
mirror we usually have
um
the
the xcv beam that's about one millimeter
in width and then because of that
grazing angle it's actually stretched so
the height is
usually like point one millimeters
thank you
next question
how thin does a transmission sample need
to be to allow xuv flux through
okay this is a good question as well so
yeah one of the complications of doing a
sample in transmission mode would be
that the xcv is going to attenuate
through
the sample as it passes through the bulk
of it
so the the thickness is typically on the
order of a few hundred nanometers
although you can again
try to tune this depending on the
material properties itself and the
attenuation coefficient as well as the
total flux of fcv you have going into
the sample
great thank you
next question
in example one
why does the negative feature electron
blue shift but the positive feature hole
not shift
okay this is a good question and this
kind of highlights why we can really
focus on
differentiating between the electrons
and holes throughout the system so
in the case of that example where we had
excited hematite the
um the polarone formation was due to the
stretching of the iron oxygen bond
and as that bond shifts or adds up on
stretches sorry the
the shift is actually due to the
electron becoming more localized on the
oxygen itself from that metal to ligand
charge transfer so we see a shift in the
electron feature but not in the whole
feature which is unaffected in this
lattice distortion
thank you
next question
what is the timeline for the nexus
project to be completed
okay this is a great question as well so
the initial nsf proposal was kind of
frameworked on this five-year plan and
we're hoping to spend
a few years in design and purchasing an
acquisition of everything and then
another couple years building and
testing all of the systems
because of the past few years we've had
a lot of shipping delays and
manufacturing delays that have slowed
this timeline down but i think we are on
on track to
have our first light this summer and
we'll begin
uh building all of the beam lines and
sort of finalizing the the end stations
themselves so that we can test and start
to accept user proposals within
hopefully the next uh two years but
i think this this type of question will
be answered in more detail at the user
workshop if anyone's interested in
joining in july
thank you it looks like we have time for
one more question
in a transmission experiment how does
the absorption through the bulk of the
sample affects the collected data
so yeah so in the transmission samples
as your activity beam goes completely
through the sample you will have an
effect of the absorption of the bulk of
your sample and because the bulk can
have
different properties and behaviors in
the surface your output data will have
a lot of information on the bulk and
depending on what you classify as the
surface which in our group would be the
first few nanometers if you go through
100 nanometers of sample you really
can't say much about what you're what
you're detecting at the surface you'll
have too much interference in the bulk
and i think this is one of the biggest
benefits of suv reflection
experimentation where you can just
isolate what's happening at the surface
layer
great and we do have time for one last
question
is the xuv technique suitable for
nanoparticle samples
okay that's a good question so
the the main limitation on the activity
technique is that everything is
happening under vacuum so our group has
started to
dabble in some more complicated and
sensitive samples
the
vacuum conditions as well as the probe
energy and intensity will
have to kind of be investigated on an
individual basis to determine the
stability of the sample but in general
nano particular samples are possible and
have been studied in a few other xv
groups so yes it is possible but a
little bit more challenging
great thank you again emily for your
time today and your important research
we would also like to thank labyrus and
our sponsor andor for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
can be viewed
and
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye
you